- Welcome back y'all,
to day four of our Rad Mama Week.
Our next guest is a chef,
author and all around Rad Mama,
who's taught us how to make everything
from TikTok pasta to
Valentine's day candy cakes,
they're all good.
Today, she's here to tell
us about her new memoir
and it's called "You Were Always There,
Notes and Recipes for
Living a Life you Love",
and it's available right
now wherever books are sold.
So let's welcome Danielle Kartes.
(Audience cheers)
(Danielle claps)
Ah, here I am, here I am!
(audience applauds)
This feels so good to be out here!
- I know, we're in a different position -
- We're in a different position -
- We're sitting -
- We're lounging -
- We're lounging-
We're in a silky dress,
- With your book.
Your dress feels so soft, by the way.
- It's so it's silky.
- Yes.
- I just wanna like roll around in it -
- I know, it's kind of like,
I would sleep in that, it's so soft.
- Yes.
I fit feels like a little
night gowny, but great.
- What did you bring though?
This is looks delicious.
- Okay. This is so great.
We have the brown butter,
dark chocolate bundt cake.
- Okay.
- That's in the book.
That's in the book,
"You Were Always There."
- [Kelly] It's also gonna be my mouth.
- Yes, it's so delicious.
And then we have the Duckhorn cab
which we can't do the
segment without some wine.
- Let's pair it, yeah.
- Yeah. Let's pair it, let's try.
- Wait, I'm gonna, I'm gonna do the -
Wait! Wait, wait! Cheers.
- Cheers.
- Cheers to the book,
cheers to on the couch.
You know, what's so cool?
So the title of the book is called.
"You Were Always There."
and I feel like so often in times we feel
like we lose ourselves.
I mean, to motherhood, to career change
to hard stuff that happens.
And I used to think
before I wrote this book
and all the things that we,
you know, we went through
I thought if I could just
get back to that girl,
if I could just get back to that girl
who was a little bit thinner,
the girl that was a little
that had a different plan.
No. And we, we miss out on so much life.
And when I was writing this
book, I thought, you know what?
You were always there.
You're always there.
That girl, that other girl she's gone,
this is who we are now.
And if we can embrace it and love it.
So that's just been a
special thing for me.
Like you get rid of the
notion that you lost yourself
because you didn't you're right here.
Right where you're supposed to be and joy
and sorrow can live together.
- Yeah.
- And the whole idea is
I wanted people to relate
back to it.
- Yeah.
- And there's just so much fun stuff.
I know there's a picture
of me and Martha Stewart.
There's a something -
- Oh my God.
So I want you to tell this story.
I love this story.
- This is the greatest story.
I feel like everybody can relate to this.
I was working on a job and
there was nowhere for me to stay
at Sundance.
And so I'm with this big
corporation and they're like,
"Well, you can stay with our
like high level executives."
I felt like an idiot.
I'm like "Me, with them?"
Like, I don't belong there.
That's not for me.
So there's nowhere for me to go.
I go to this house and they're like,
"Well we have this dinner
with Martha Stewart later."
And I was like, "well, can I go?"
And they said, "No, you can't go!
Like, you're just in the house
'cause you have to be
in the house." And...
- I love that you asked
though, you never know.
- Yeah, you have to ask!
- Yeah.
- So then a couple minutes
later, one of the ladies knocks
on my door and she's like,
"You know what we were thinking about it,
we're paying for it, why can't you go?"
And I was like, "Yes!"
So I get there.
I didn't bring anything cute to wear.
I had this weird tight blazer.
So I throw the tight
blazer on and I'm like
"I'm going to the dinner,
I'm going to the dinner."
Well, if there's only a
hundred people in this room
so I'm like trying to find her,
trying to like sneak attack
with pictures cos I'm the
weird one at the table.
Have nothing in common
with any of these ladies.
And I'm getting the
picture like queued up,
her she is.
And we make, we literally
lock eyes in my camera
and I was like, "holy, oh
my God, please Lord kill me.
I mean, don't kill me
make me pass out or something."
She saw me.
Then she starts walking
towards me and I'm like
"I have just humiliated
myself beyond belief."
And she walks in, she walks in.
I'm like "What's happening?"
And she goes, "Did we get it?"
(audience laughing)
- She does does have that low voice.
That low voice like soothing, yeah.
- And I said, "No, we didn't get it."
She goes, "Pull your phone back out."
So I pulled it out and
snapped this picture
and it just, this, it was this
big light bulb moment for me.
Like you belong at the
table, ask for a seat.
- Yeah.
- You belong there.
So this whole book is really
about really hard times living
with really great times,
being super broken, poor
and finding our way and figuring
out that you never left.
- Do you think that
that drives you though?
Because I feel like that's what drove me.
I had nothing to lose cuz
I had already lost so much.
- And it's neat when we
share, because when you
share your story and your
hardship and the things
that you've gone through
you unlock possibilities for other people.
- Because they go, "Wait,
if they did it, then I can."
- Then I can do it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And when you tell somebody else,
then the shame leaves too.
Like, oh my gosh, I know
what that's like to wake
up in the morning and play beat the bank
hit the ATM before the red,
all the bills come out
and it's red for the week.
- Yeah.
I think we're from the
same kind of background.
- Girl. I know. We both go through forty.
- Forties are gonna be so good.
- [Danielle] They're so good.
- Thank you so much, Danielle.
- I love this.
- You're welcome.
- We have to cook more
but also do this more-
- Yes!
- And that cake is delicious.
- Oh, it's so good here.
- I just totally did.
- The top is actually the best part.
- I know cuz it's like kind of crispy.
We are soulmates.
- So good.
- Okay. Yeah. That's so good.
Everybody be sure to pick
up Danielle's newest book.
"You Were Always There,
Notes and recipes for
living a life you love"
wherever books are sold, you can find it.
You can also find the recipe
for this incredible brown butter,
just saying brown butter
makes my mouth water,
brown butter, chocolate
bundt cake in there.
And everyone in the
audience can make it tonight
because you're all going home with a copy!
(imitates air horn blasting)
(audience cheers)